.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Das stresst mich
jetzt schon drei Tage.
Ich kann nicht mehr.
Dieser idiotische Autopilot.
* Er knurrt. *
* Eindringliche,
aufschwingende Musik *
Ich brauche das Meer,
ich brauche das Segeln.
Das ist mein Leben, mein Beruf
und das Einzige, was ich kann.
Da vorne sieht es nach Flaute aus.
Das ist nicht gerade lustig.
Allein um den Globus,
so schnell wie möglich -
im härtesten Rennen der Welt.
Alan Roura ist 80 Tage und Nächte
nonstop unterwegs.
Wir riskieren unser Leben.
Wir lassen unsere Familien zurück,
um zu segeln.
Das Abenteuer
kommt vor allem anderen.
Ich muss da hochklettern,
und zwar jetzt.
Ich werde noch sterben, verdammt!
46'000 km ...
Yes! Juhu!
... bis der Schweizer Extremsegler
wieder zu Hause ist.
Sie ist schön, oder?
Hallo, mein Schatz.
Sie hat wohl gleich volle Windeln.
Oh, nein.
Seine kleine Billie
ist erst drei Monate alt.
Wir verbringen oft Stunden damit,
einander in die Augen zu schauen.
Ich singe kleine Lieder
und versuche, sie kennenzulernen.
Weil für sie und für mich
alles neu ist, lernen wir zusammen.
Das ist schön.
Manchmal ist sie auf meinen Knien
und wir schauen uns nur an.
Wir lernen einander einfach kennen.
Billie ist während der Vorbereitungen
für die Vendée Globe
zur Welt gekommen,
der härtesten Segelregatta der Welt.
Wegen seiner Liebe zum Meer
und zum Segelsport
hat es ihn nach Lorient
in der Bretagne verschlagen -
60'000 Einwohner, und doch
ist es ein verschlafenes Nest.
Alan Roura und seine Frau Aurélia
haben sich vor rund zwei Jahren
ein kleines Eckhaus gekauft.
Es ist noch früh am Morgen.
Alan und Aurélia geniessen
diesen seltenen Moment der Ruhe.
Wenn wir mal zusammen frühstücken,
ist das ein Moment nur für uns.
Wir haben fast nie frei.
Wir arbeiten immer 100 %.
Vielleicht nicht körperlich,
aber mental.
Wir leben fürs Segelprojekt.
Wenn wir nur schon
5 Min. für uns haben
und zusammen einen Kaffee
trinken können, tut das gut.
Sie sind ein starkes Team.
Aurélia managt für Alan fast alles,
wenn er an der härtesten Regatta
der Welt teilnimmt.
Mir wird seine Anwesenheit fehlen.
Wir führen eine sehr enge Beziehung
und verbringen viel Zeit zusammen.
Wenn er nicht da ist,
kann ich gut damit umgehen,
ich bin es gewohnt,
mit einem Einhandsegler zu leben.
Ich weiss,
worauf ich mich eingelassen habe.
Klar, seine Abwesenheit
geht immer auch an die Gefühle,
aber zu Hause gibt es mit Billie,
unserem Hund Luna und der Arbeit
immer viel zu tun.
Aber er wird mir fehlen.
Mit ihm an meiner Seite
fühle ich mich einfach gut.
Wenn er nicht da ist,
fehlt ein Teil von mir.
Vor vier Jahren hatte Alan
ein Schlüsselerlebnis.
Er war 2016 der jüngste Teilnehmer
an der Vendée Globe.
Weit über 100'000 Zuschauer waren
live in Les Sables-d'Olonne dabei.
Millionen
verfolgten den Start am Bildschirm.
Alan war erst 23, und die ganze Welt
schaute erstaunt und mit Respekt
auf den jungen Genfer Extremsportler.
Das ist wohl
der schönste Tag meines Lebens.
Es gibt keine Worte dafür.
Ein Traum geht in Erfüllung,
und ich bin extrem stolz und
berührt, heute hier sein zu können.
Nur 30 Topsegler waren am Start -
Helden voller Mut und Abenteuerlust.
Die Menschen jubelten.
Die Regatta ist gefährlich
und fordert Nerven und Ausdauer.
Manch einer verunfallt
und kommt nie mehr zurück.
(Mann) Trois, deux, un, go!
Die Schnellsten
sind rund 80 Tage unterwegs.
Einmal nonstop rund um die Welt,
ganz allein
und Hitze, Eis,
Sturm und Flaute ausgesetzt.
Sie schlafen nur kurz
und sind immer auf der Hut.
Jederzeit
kann man Schiffbruch erleiden,
oder haushohe Wellen spülen
hilflose Segler von ihrer 20-m-Jacht.
Dann ist man verloren,
ertrinkt, stirbt.
Alan Roura schaffte vor vier Jahren,
was ihm die wenigsten zutrauten.
Er erreichte nach 105 Tagen trotz
grosser Schäden am Boot das Ziel.
Fast wäre er untergegangen.
Die Ankunft war eine Triumphfahrt.
Sein zwölfter Rang war unwichtig,
denn jeder, der die Weltumsegelung
überhaupt schafft, ist ein Held
und wird gefeiert wie ein Sieger.
Knapp die Hälfte kam nicht ins Ziel,
hatte aufgegeben -
entkräftet, mental am Ende
oder wegen eines kaputten Schiffs.
Ich finde keine Worte,
um die Vendée Globe zu beschreiben.
Man müsste
ein Buch darüber schreiben.
Es ist unglaublich.
Es war hart. Es waren hauptsächlich
sehr schwierige Bedingungen.
Ich hatte wirklich zu kämpfen,
aber es war auf jeden Fall
das schönste Erlebnis,
das ich je hatte.
Allein die Welt zu umsegeln,
die drei Kaps zu passieren ...
Ich habe gefunden,
was ich zu finden gehofft habe:
die Angst,
die Gefahr, das Adrenalin,
das Lachen, das Weinen, die Freude,
die Pannen, die Reparaturen -
alles,
was das Einhandsegeln ausmacht.
Dieser Kampf
bei der Weltumsegelung.
Mit diesem Erfolg wurde Alan bekannt.
Sein Boot war damals
eines der ältesten überhaupt,
sein Budget eines der kleinsten.
Dieser Triumph
stachelt ihn erst richtig an.
Wenn man etwas
zum ersten Mal macht,
ist man ahnungslos.
Man kennt es nicht, es ist neu.
Man riskiert sein Leben
und fragt sich, warum man das tut.
Trotzdem ist es im Rückblick
so unglaublich schön,
dass man Lust hat,
wieder dabei zu sein.
Ich habe Lust,
diese Gefühle wieder zu erleben.
Es ist, wie mit dem Fallschirm
aus dem Flugzeug zu springen.
Dieser Adrenalinschub bewirkt,
dass man dasselbe
noch einmal erleben möchte.
Ist es das Adrenalin, der Kick,
der Abenteurer Alan
immer wieder aufs Neue
aufs offene Meer zieht?
Simon Koster, selbst Profisegler,
kennt Alan seit Langem.
Sie sind auch schon
zusammen gesegelt.
Man glaubt immer, man könne es
noch etwas besser machen.
Dadurch besteht auch ein Ansporn,
jedes Mal noch etwas mehr zu pushen
und sich das noch einmal anzutun.
Noch einmal drei Monate lang
allein unterwegs zu sein.
Das ist wahrscheinlich eine Sucht.
Es ist eine Passion.
Wenn man die hat,
ist der Drang immer da,
noch ein Stück weiter zu gehen
und wieder aufs Meer zu gehen.
Die Vendée Globe ist für Segler
wie der Mount Everest für Alpinisten.
Jeder Profi-Einhandsegler
träumt davon.
Es fasziniert, dass die Extremsegler
drei Monate lang
Tag und Nacht
schnellstmöglich die Welt umschiffen,
weit weg von Land und Mensch.
Allein und ohne Hilfe.
Was ist das Schlimmste,
das passieren kann?
Das Schlimmste ist eine Kollision,
die man nicht vorhersehen kann.
Oder ein Mastbruch,
ein Materialfehler.
Eine Kollision oder so etwas,
wegen der man das Rennen
abrupt aufgeben muss.
Oder vielleicht
noch gefährlicher ...
Das Schlimmste ist,
wenn man über Bord geht.
Das ist bei so einer Regatta
in den meisten Fällen tödlich.
Oh, mein kleines Baby.
Bist du gerade erwacht?
Oh, là, là, là, oui, oui.
Ich liebe es,
wenn sie morgens aufwacht.
Ihre Augen sind dann noch schwer,
aber sie schaut ihren Papa an
und schenkt ihm ein kleines Lächeln.
Als würde sie sagen:
"Guten Morgen, Papa."
Diese Momente sind
einfach unvergesslich, wie so viele.
Ich werde sie
drei Monate nicht sehen.
Ich freue mich aber
umso mehr auf meine Rückkehr.
Vielleicht krabbelt sie dann schon.
Es zerreisst Alan das Herz,
wenn er seine kleine Tochter
zurücklassen muss,
aber seine Liebe zum Segelabenteuer
ist grösser und fordert Opfer.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob sie
seine Abwesenheit wahrnehmen wird.
Der Vorteil ist,
dass sie sich kaum erinnern kann.
Wenn er zurück ist, wird sie
ihn schnell wieder annehmen.
Wenn Billie etwas älter wäre,
wäre es wahrscheinlich
schwieriger für beide.
Eigentlich
ist sie in einem guten Alter.
Natürlich wird sie sich
noch nicht so weit entwickelt haben,
wenn er wiederkommt.
Sie wird in dieser Zeit
nicht gehen und sprechen lernen.
Es ist wichtig
im Leben eines jungen Papas,
nicht zu viele Entwicklungsschritte
zu verpassen.
Ich versuche, nicht daran zu denken.
Ein Neugeborenes zurückzulassen,
ist nicht einfach.
Am schwierigsten ist es, Aurélia
in dieser Zeit allein zu lassen.
Noch schwieriger, als Billie
eine Weile nicht zu sehen.
Dass Aurélia
alles allein stemmen muss,
quält mich am meisten.
Im Hafen von Lorient
wirken die Militärbunker
aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg bedrohlich.
Hier hat sich die französische
Segelszene installiert.
Mittendrin: Alan und sein Team.
Monatelang bereiten sie sich
auf die Vendée Globe vor.
Sie haben für das Projekt
4 Mio. Fr. zur Verfügung -
wenig, im Vergleich zu
den 15 Mio. der Topteams.
Das Boot ist 13 Jahre alt
und kostet 1 Mio. Fr.,
die Hightech-Jachten
der Konkurrenten 6-7 Mio.
Ja, ich habe ein älteres Schiff.
Ich habe es gezähmt. Ich kenne es.
Ich habe
ein Gefühl dafür entwickelt.
Auch wenn es etwas langsamer ist,
habe ich so die gleichen Chancen
wie jemand mit einem neuen
und viel schnelleren Schiff.
Ich habe nicht das schnellste Boot,
aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Ich habe ein Schiff,
mit dem man am Ziel ankommt.
Mit dem Architekten und dem
Bootsbauer wird festgelegt,
was beim Schiff
weiter optimiert werden muss.
Alan ist Chef
des sechsköpfigen Teams.
Der 27-Jährige spürt den Druck.
Ich lerne immer noch dazu.
Ich mache mir ziemlich Druck,
und auch mein Team macht Druck.
Und sie haben recht,
denn ich brauche das.
Ich brauche
einen Tritt in den Hintern,
um auf dem Wasser schnell zu sein.
Das Ziel ist, alles zu geben.
Unterschriften für die Fans.
Magst du das nicht?
- Ich hasse das.
Aurélia und Alan
haben sich vor sieben Jahren
bei einem Segelrennen kennengelernt.
Sie war damals TV-Journalistin.
Geht's nicht?
- Nein, es geht nicht.
Wir müssen neue Stifte kaufen.
Sonst machen wir es
mit Kugelschreibern.
Nein, das ist nicht schön so.
Die beiden sind ehrgeizig
und wollen erfolgreich sein.
Geht's nicht?
- Nein, es geht nicht.
Hast du viele Fans?
Ja, und das ist cool.
Aurélia
ist fünf Jahre älter als Alan
und weiss genau, wie sie ihren Mann
am besten unterstützen kann.
Alan
scheint ein lockerer Typ zu sein,
der immer fröhlich ist,
lacht und keinen Stress hat.
Aber er macht sich selbst
sehr viel Druck.
Manchmal zweifelt er auch
an seinem Potenzial.
Aber diese Zweifel sind auch gut,
weil er sich permanent hinterfragt.
Er ist nie zu selbstsicher,
und dadurch entwickelt er sich auch.
Das ist eine Stärke.
Aber er versteckt diese Seite oft.
Wenn er so zweifelt, müssen wir
ihn manchmal etwas anspornen.
Dann sagt er, wir seien streng,
aber am nächsten Tag sagt er,
dass wir Recht hatten.
Er habe das gebraucht.
Er ist jung.
Ich sage ihm oft:
"Du musst dranbleiben."
Alan Roura und Aurélia Mouraud -
zwei, die sich gefunden haben.
Im Juni 2019 heirateten die beiden
in einem Gewächshaus.
Wir haben an einem
sehr besonderen Ort geheiratet,
weil wir so sind.
Ein Schloss
hätte nicht zu uns gepasst.
Sie sah wunderschön aus.
Unsere Familien
und Freunde waren da,
und trotzdem gab es in diesem Moment
nur uns beide.
Aurélia hat mir
einen Weg zur Welt gezeigt.
Sie unterstützt mich
und warnt mich manchmal auch.
Es ist wichtig, jemand anderen
als die Familie zu haben,
um sich weiterzuentwickeln.
Ich habe nicht nur
die Frau meines Lebens,
sondern auch
meine beste Freundin geheiratet.
Alan Roura, ein Verrückter
aus dem Binnenland Schweiz,
ein Genfer, der das Meer liebt
und die Weltmeere erobern will.
Irgendwie eine besondere Geschichte,
für Alan aber
das Normalste der Welt.
Ich habe immer
vom Einhandsegeln geträumt.
Ich habe mir aber immer eingeredet,
es wäre wohl nichts für mich,
weil ich nicht
dem Standard entspreche.
Normalerweise muss man ja
die Segelschule besuchen,
für Olympia trainieren, usw.
Aber mit 18 sagte ich mir:
"Egal, ob ich
dem Profil entspreche oder nicht,
ich muss es einfach probieren."
Und jetzt bin ich hier.
Wenn man etwas tun will,
muss man daran glauben.
Wir riskieren unser Leben.
Wir lassen unsere Familien
und alles zurück, um zu segeln.
Das Abenteuer
kommt vor allem anderen.
Ich brauche das Meer,
ich brauche das Segeln.
Das ist mein Leben,
meine Leidenschaft, mein Beruf
und das Einzige, was ich kann.
In Sainte-Croix, einen Katzensprung
vom Genfersee entfernt,
leben Alans Eltern.
Alan hat nur noch selten Zeit,
um seine Eltern zu besuchen.
Hierher muss man kommen,
um zu verstehen,
warum Alan zu dem geworden ist,
der er heute ist.
Seine Eltern
haben nämlich vor langer Zeit
einen folgenschweren Entscheid
gefällt.
Das war vor über 20 Jahren,
als Alan sechs Jahre alt war.
Ich mochte die Schule nie.
Meine Eltern zwangen mich immer
in die Schule, wie alle Kinder,
die mit fünf bis sieben Jahren
zur Schule gehen müssen.
Eines Tages kam Alan in das Alter,
in dem man zur Schule geht.
Ich fragte ihn, ob er
zur Schule gehen wolle oder nicht.
Und er sagte Nein.
Also ging ich zur Schule nach Genf,
um ihn nicht einzuschreiben.
Der Vater, selbst Segler,
wollte damals aussteigen
und auf unbestimmte Zeit weggehen.
Er überzeugte seine Frau
und die vier Kinder,
zusammen um die Welt zu segeln.
Elf Jahre waren sie gemeinsam
auf allen Weltmeeren unterwegs.
Alan war schon mit zwei Jahren
auf einem Boot.
Es war klar,
dass er nie in einem Büro arbeiten
oder in die Schule gehen würde.
Er liebte
sein Leben auf dem Wasser so sehr,
dass es nicht anders sein konnte.
Sie unterrichteten Alan,
ihren Jüngsten, selbst.
Alan genoss
dieses Leben auf dem Meer.
Die Freiheit und die Weite
lernte er lieben und schätzen.
Die Beziehung zu meinen Eltern
ist sehr wichtig.
Dank ihnen
bin ich heute da, wo ich bin.
Ich lebe dieses Leben
seit meiner Kindheit.
In einem Büro
wäre ich nicht glücklich.
Mein Leben
sind das Segeln und das Meer.
Es ist schwierig, meinen Eltern
direkt dafür zu danken.
Vielleicht ist das,
was ich heute mache,
meine Art,
ihnen meine Dankbarkeit zu zeigen.
Die Eltern
sind stolz auf ihren Jüngsten,
der so ins Segeln vernarrt ist.
Sie freuen sich über seine Erfolge
und darüber,
wie er immer besser wird.
Weil sie aber auch wissen,
wie gefährlich Alans Abenteuer sind,
beschäftigen sie auch
Sorgen und Angst.
Bei der ersten Vendée Globe,
während der drei Monate,
schlief ich
nicht mehr als 2 Std. pro Nacht.
Jeden Morgen freute ich mich,
wenn mir der Navigator
die Position des Bootes
auf dem Computer anzeigte.
Ich überlegte mir dauernd Lösungen,
damit ich ihn im Notfall
hätte retten können.
Ich habe immer Angst.
Ich bin eine sehr behütende Mama.
Wirklich, ich schlafe kaum,
wenn er auf dem Meer ist,
aber ich weiss,
dass er vorsichtig ist.
Ich vertraue ihm.
Allez, cinq secondes!
Allez, allez.
Yes!
Quinze secondes.
Alan hat sich einen richtigen
Folterknecht ins Team geholt,
einen Fitnesscoach
und Karatemeister.
Alan war die letzten Wochen krank.
Jetzt muss er seine Fitness
und Kraft wieder aufbauen.
V.a. die Beine sind noch schwach.
Allez, allez.
Ah, putain!
Ich steuere
ein 18 m langes Schiff ganz allein.
Da muss man
einiges aushalten können.
Es geht nicht nur
um Stärke oder Ausdauer,
sondern darum,
dass man sich nicht verletzt.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Zwei- bis dreimal pro Woche
schindet er sich.
Kein Erfolg ohne Leidensbereitschaft.
Nur mit einer exzellenten Physis
hat er Chancen,
die Strapazen der härtesten Regatta
der Welt zu überstehen
und das Ziel zu erreichen.
Man gibt sich
heftige Tritte in den Hintern,
um zu wissen,
was man auf dem Meer
alles leisten kann.
Die Vendée Globe
ist ständig in Alans Kopf.
Gedanken, welche Entbehrungen
ihn erwarten, prägen sein Denken.
* Stöhnen *
Umso mehr geniesst er die wenigen
angenehmen Momente der Vorbereitung.
Kommt jetzt der gute Teil?
- Ja, klar.
Manchmal will man sagen,
man brauche eine Massage,
um es sich gut gehen zu lassen.
Ce sont les bons moments, ça.
Probleme und Gefahren können
beim Segeln urplötzlich auftreten,
wie z.B. bei einem
Transatlantikrennen vor zwei Jahren.
Damals ging es von der Bretagne
in die Karibik.
Jusqu'au bout, quoi.
Jusqu'au bout.
Ganz oben, verdammt.
Die Fixierung des Hauptsegels
ist gerissen.
Ich gehe da hoch und repariere es,
und zwar jetzt.
Ich muss hochklettern und beten ...
... beten, dass es ...
Scheisse. Dass alles klappt.
Das klappt schon.
Es gibt Momente,
in denen man sich nicht gut fühlt.
Immer allein zu sein,
ist schwierig -
immer auf dem Meer,
sich selbst motivieren ...
Da muss man relativieren können.
Aber man hat sich dafür entschieden.
Man hat unterschrieben,
dabei zu sein.
Diese Momente sind umso wichtiger,
weil man dann wieder weiss,
warum man das macht.
Weil es ein Traum ist
und man sein Ding durchziehen will.
Los geht's.
Alan will auf keinen Fall aufgeben.
Darum klettert er
trotz harten Windes und Wellen
allein auf den 27 m hohen Mast,
um das Problem zu beheben.
Verdammt!
Ein Leben ohne jegliche Angst
ergibt keinen Sinn.
Das Leben ist gemacht,
um seine Ängste zu überwinden.
Ich habe Angst vor vielem,
deshalb liebe ich meinen Job.
Ich frage mich jeden Tag,
warum ich das tue.
Man braucht Ängste,
um zu wachsen
und sich weiterzuentwickeln.
Stück für Stück
kämpft sich Alan zur Mastspitze vor.
Er muss das kaputte Stück ersetzen
und das Seil lösen,
wenn er sein Segel
wieder setzen will.
Ich sterbe noch, das ist sicher.
Alles wegen dieses Segels.
Am Ende schafft er es tatsächlich.
Wie sehr die Entbehrungen
auf hoher See einem zusetzen,
wenn man wochenlang allein ist,
kann Simon Koster nachvollziehen.
Er kennt die Bedingungen
aus eigener Erfahrung.
V.a. der Schlafentzug
macht den Abenteurern zu schaffen.
Während der Vendée Globe schlafen
die Skipper vielleicht 1-2 Std.,
wenn sie
weit vom Land entfernt sind,
wenn sie im Südpolarmeer sind
oder irgendwo,
wo es nicht viel Verkehr gibt.
Aber in Gebieten mit mehr Verkehr
schlafen sie nur 30 Min. am Stück.
Das sind also nur Powernaps.
Diese muss man
so über den Tag verteilen,
dass man im Durchschnitt trotzdem
auf etwa 6 Std. Schlaf kommt.
Der Schlafmangel
macht Alan sicher zu schaffen.
Am Anfang hat man Mühe,
sich zu konzentrieren.
Es ist möglich,
dass man Halluzinationen bekommt.
Es kann sein, dass man Dinge hört,
die nicht existieren.
Ich höre z.B. jemanden pfeifen,
wenn die Halluzinationen beginnen.
Oder ich höre Rufe.
In einem zweiten Schritt
habe ich visuelle Halluzinationen.
Ich sehe Dinge, die es nicht gibt:
ein Fischerboot,
einen Baumstamm im Wasser.
Bald wird aus dem Familienvater
ein einsamer Kämpfer,
der monatelang allein
Wind, Wellen und Strömung trotzt,
statt sein Baby im Arm zu halten.
Aurélia weiss gut,
welche Gefahren auf ihn warten.
Ich mache mir nie
allzu viele Sorgen.
Dazu kommt, dass ich Alan vertraue.
Wenn er losgeht, weiss ich,
dass er am meisten Bock hat,
wieder zurückzukommen -
gerade jetzt, wo auch Billie da ist.
Aber es stimmt: Es gibt Gedanken,
die ich vorher nicht hatte.
Z.B., dass Billie
ohne ihren Vater älter wird.
Das sind Gedanken, die ich schnell
zu verdrängen versuche.
Und es betrifft mehr
meine Tochter als mich.
Mit der Geburt eines Babys
verändert sich die Sicht auf alles.
Aber ich vertraue ihm.
Seit er Vater geworden sei,
habe er sich schon etwas verändert.
Er wolle seine Tochter mit
seinen Segelleistungen stolz machen.
Aber auch Zweifel
tauchen immer wieder auf.
Es gibt Phasen, in denen man denkt:
"Warum tue ich das?
Warum bin ich allein hier?"
"Warum habe ich keinen normalen Job,
komme jeden Tag nach Hause
und habe Wochenenden und Ferien?"
"Warum gehe ich dieses Risiko ein?"
Ich spiele
mit den Gefühlen der Menschen,
denn das Risiko einzugehen,
nicht nach Hause zu kommen,
ist sehr egoistisch.
Aber diese Fragen
sind jeweils nicht zu lange im Kopf.
Während des Rennens
wird man abgelenkt
vom Wasser, dem Meer,
dem Klassement ...
Aurélia kommt bisher recht gut
mit Alans langer Abwesenheit klar.
Weil nun aber Billie bei ihnen ist,
wird es dieses Mal anders sein.
Dieses Mal wird es
beim Abschied anders sein,
weil sich mit einem Baby
schon etwas verändert hat.
Der Rhythmus zwischen Arbeit
und Billie wird hart.
Das könnte
etwas komplizierter werden.
Aber ich bin nicht die Erste,
der das passiert.
Ich habe viel Unterstützung -
das ist wichtig.
Ich mache mir
nicht allzu viele Sorgen.
Ich denke,
für Alan ist es fast schwieriger.
* Melancholische, langsame Musik *
Am 8. November ist es so weit.
* Treibende, elektronische Klänge *
Kein grosser Zirkus, keine Zuschauer.
Wegen COVID-19 ist alles anders
als vor vier Jahren.
Ohne Emotionen gibt es keinen Start
in die Vendée Globe.
Man hat Angst, es ist was Schönes,
aber man lässt
viele geliebte Menschen zurück.
Ein unglaubliches Abenteuer.
Wir haben bisher so viel
in dieses Projekt investiert.
Ich bin sehr stolz, hier zu sein.
Bis vor Kurzem
waren wir noch Konkurrenten,
aber heute sind wir irgendwie
alle eine Familie,
die zusammen aufs Wasser geht.
Es wird eine lange Reise.
Wir werden uns
gegenseitig unterstützen.
Der Abschied heute ist magisch.
Es ist ein schöner Moment.
Mit Alan kämpfen 33 andere
um Erfolg und Ruhm
gegen sich und die Weltmeere.
Das nächste Abenteuer beginnt.
Welche Gefahren und Abenteuer
warten dieses Mal auf Alan?
Wird er die Welt umsegeln
und gesund zu Billie
und Aurélia zurückkommen?
Niemand kennt die Antwort.
* Antreibende Poprock-Musik *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
A. Duttweiler, D. McMinn - 2020